pete doherty from the green bay press
gazette joins us now to talk
all things packers welcome to the show
pete how you doing buddy
good good ryan how are you today i'm
doing good how uh
how are things going out there nothing
to write about this summer it looks like
yeah it's uh the circus kind of came
back to town um
but you know it's it's just it's going
to be kind of a dead period i mean
there's going to be little
snippets of news between now and the
start of camp but
you know the next big date is whether he
shows for the start of camp
and if he doesn't show for that then
it's whether he shows
for the first game and uh even with the
start of camp that's when things will
get really interesting if he
if he doesn't show because that'll begin
to suggest
how serious he really is about uh
wanting to get out of here
yeah um talking with pete doherty from
the green bay press gazette again about
this packer situation
um has it uh i mean you have your
contacts you
you have your sources and things like
that but is it is it
leading to a possible return for the
season because we haven't
heard uh haven't heard aaron rodgers
blatantly
come out and say it on the record like i
do not
want to be here i'm not going to be here
we've heard it from different ways
we've heard that he's had a problem with
it with kenny mayne on sportscenter but
we haven't heard like that ultimatum
like i'm done i'm out i'm not playing
there again
yeah we've heard it from surrogates so
you know i believe that it's true to at
least some degree that he wants out
but you know the real proof will be what
kind of financial hit
he's willing to take is he willing to
you know set out a season is he willing
to even
you know retire for a season or maybe
longer
um so i you know i believe it's true
that there's
you know that he's he's pretty serious
but i waiver i keep going back and forth
on whether he'll actually
pull the trigger or not i don't you know
since the stuff broke
you know right at the draft i've been
basically hovering around sixty forty
that he won't be there he won't be back
and he won't be the quarterback this
year
and just in the last week or so i've
kind of flip-flopped it
to 60-40 he will be some of the things
james jones
has been saying you know make me think
maybe rogers
you know is kinda land a little
groundwork for for coming back and
having the plausible deniability you
talked about there because he never
actually
said i definitely want out um but
you know on the other hand devonte adams
you know when he's talked about it
he's in touch with rogers he's seemed he
didn't seem super optimistic
so really the only people who might know
might be
you know rogers and his fiance and his
agent
and maybe even they aren't sure you know
what the ultimate decision will be until
it's time to make it uh
what what is aaron rodgers legacy if he
doesn't come back
if he decides to retire with three mvps
a super bowl title and
you know essentially four nfc
championship losses that could have got
him back is it
uh is it a place where uh he's seen as
the greatest green bay packers
quarterback of all time or does he need
that that other
championship to exceed uh brett favre
and and get
get to the same level as part star yeah
i would think
um he would need to win another
championship to get past farv
you know right now they're they're neck
and neck they each have their strengths
i mean what i mean they're both i mean
rogers
will be a no-brainer no-brainer
hall-of-famer if i'm still on the i'm a
whole same voter if i'm still on the
committee
my speech for you know my presentation
for him will be as long as it was for
far which was like nine seconds i think
so you know right hill hill riders will
go down as one of the great
greatest pure passers uh the game has
ever seen
um a fantastic you know great player
help build the title town district out
here which is gonna be uh
you know it's a business district next
to lambeau field which the packers own
and it'll be a revenue stream for
decades to come for this franchise so
it's you know it's done the franchise a
lot he'll
he'll have all those things but he'll
also have you know the championship
losses some of which
um you know he bears little or no
responsibility but one or two of which
he's right in the thick of being
responsible for the loss so
you know it'll be a mix but obviously
you know push comes to shove he's he
goes down as one of the
all-time great quarterbacks uh if he
were to quit right now and you know
like you say i mean he could have three
to five real good years left i mean
who knows uh you know they have a good
team or whoever else he might
end up with he could win another super
bowl or two
real easily yeah if you look what tom
brady did from age 38 to 45 essentially
43
i think he was played for four
championships so that's and i also think
that has something to do with it i think
that aaron saw what tom was able to do
and i just don't know if there's a
a landing spot for him that's a better
place to win a championship
than in green bay because uh they need
each other right green bay's win loss
record may be hovering around seven or
or eight wins without aaron rodgers and
that's that's giving a lot of credit to
jordan love
uh as a is a essentially rookie
quarterback if he gets the call
um this this seems like
a uh uh a terrible hill to die on
because
he found his voice this offseason when i
thought the perfect opportunity for him
to voice his like dominance and like
leadership
and i'm the guy was in the nfc
championship when he walked off the
field
and allowed the team to walk on and kick
a field goal there that was the moment
and where he puts his hand up to the
floor
and says no if we're gonna if we're
gonna lose this game it's gonna be on my
arm i'm the leader here it is now this
is where i
i told the line and i was i was shocked
that
that that didn't happen and then this
off seasons when he chose to kind of
take the stand then uh um around his
his what he thinks is his position with
the green bay packers
yeah i know you know i mean if love is
their quarterback even if love turns out
to be a really really good player i mean
i think four or five wins is probably
more well
more more realistic i mean they were
rogers was in his fourth year
in the league when he became a starter
and
look how great he's turned out to be and
they went six and ten his first year as
a starter so
it's just tough sledding with the rookie
with a really really young quarterback
has never been a star before no matter
you know no matter who the guy is and
yeah but for sure this is their best
this is
roger's best chance to win the super
bowl obviously the packers need him to
win one
uh there's nobody that they'd be willing
to trade him to now who would have a
better chance in the packers this year
for sure
and they're set up to be really good you
know this year and probably next year
unless some
strange things happen with uh with
serious injuries and in that
championship game they were you know
they had
there's plenty of responsibility to go
around there's that touchdown they gave
up about basically the last place
of the first half um dante adams dropped
a touchdown pass
early that they on a third down so they
had to kick a field goal
uh joe aaron jones fumbled on the first
possession the second half that gave
the bucks some free points but you know
the packers did get the ball back twice
on interceptions
early in the fourth quarter down five
and one three and out with six straight
passes
both times and they got down there and
had a chance to score and
uh he didn't get them and so there's
responsibility for for everybody in that
game
and that you know what that's one of the
questions rogers has to answer is what
himself is what's more important is he
does he want out so badly that he's
willing
to walk away from what will be his best
chance to win a super bowl at least this
year and maybe for the next couple years
he learned
even in his in the floors first season
how hard it can be
adjusting to not a new offense they went
thirteen and three
in the force first year and thirteen and
three last year they were so much better
they were such a
better team last season and their
offense was so much better
and one of the reasons was it was
roger's second season
in the offense so he he had the thing
down cold which
even with a veteran guy who's been
around forever and is a great player as
a really bright guy
if they're still that adjustment a
period to a new offense so if he goes to
a new team
you know he's got to endure that too
we're talking with pete doherty from the
green bay press gazette
about the packer situation uh
around aaron rodgers now let me ask you
a question about jordan love right
because
this guy didn't ask for any of this he
came out of utah state
just wanted to be a professional
quarterback he gets drafted by an
organization which he should be
incredibly proud of because they've had
a
a lineage of great quarterback play and
how they've developed quarterbacks
instead he gets thrown into a mix where
there's a feud between rogers in the
front office
and then this year rogers decides not to
show up which i think is the best thing
for jordan love to get more snaps
but every practice is going to be over
scrutinized so if he if he has a bad
practice it's going to be the end of the
world if he has a good practice
the hyperbolic uh clamoring for this guy
to be the guy then
happens it's it's it's really unfair to
the young man i know you decide to be a
first round
draft pick or you don't decide you
decide to go pro and you are a first
round draft pick there it comes with
pressures
but it seems uh incredibly unfair to a
guy that had
no say in any of this it is
and um i guess it's one of those many
things in the world where
you know i guess fairness has not done
that much to do with it right
it's just it's just the way it is and uh
he's got to live with it but one thing
i mean i you are a hundred percent right
and it doesn't hurt the packers at all
to not have rogers here this offseason
he doesn't need the work sure you'd
rather have him here than that but he
doesn't need to work with with these
guys
he can come in and two weeks into camp
he's right where he would have been
anyway
so that's not an issue at all um but
love got
i've never seen this i've been covering
this team since 93 and i've never seen
this before you know always in
practice that are open to the media you
know training camp many camps all that
if there's a fourteen play period the
starter takes the first four
um the backup will take two or three
and the number three will take one or
two you know the patterns vary a little
bit but that's basically it
in this camp love took in the mini camp
where they were going full speed
he took 95 to 98 percent of the snaps uh
uh uh somebody else on the beat rob
demofsky of espn he counted up the snaps
that he took and he took
love took more snaps in the three-day
mini camp
than he took in all of training again
eleven on eleven that he took in all of
training camp last year
so he got a ton of work really valuable
you're right it was so over scrutinized
his first day was really unimpressive i
mean
it was just why he did nothing second
day he had four or five just
really really good throws you go okay
this is what made this guy a first round
pick
and the third day was kind of in between
so you're right every and every day in
camp is going to be scrutinized but he's
just
he's just got to live with it and keep
his eye on the target which is you know
becoming
a better quarterback and getting himself
ready to play in case he's needed
pete doherty again from the green bay
press gazette talking all thing packers
um
i talked about who blinks first in this
scenario the green bay packers have
absolutely uh um i i feel have all the
leverage here
they simply decide whether he'll be
traded wherever he wants you know
where wherever they want to trade him if
they decide to do that uh
if they feel like jordan love is is
improved enough where he can be a guy to
lead him someplace early on that that's
that's something but i also think that
uh to your point aaron could show up
uh you know the monday of of week one
and uh go to work and be the guy i
i don't think he'd do that i think he'd
come maybe the last week of the
preseason
but you're 60 in terms of him playing
for the packers mine
mine verges more on the 80 20. i think
he's back
i think he wants to win that second
championship this is the best
opportunity for him to do it and i think
it would be incredibly powerful
if he were able to do it uh uh you know
and show ryan gudenkouts that it doesn't
matter it you know it doesn't matter
uh i'm the i'm the the straw that stirs
the drink and you're gonna see why when
this is all said and done
yeah you know and when in throwing those
numbers around here you're probably
right
and but yeah i just hit the the thing
that gives me pause is
you know i think it was mike freeman who
were used to work but new york times and
he's with bleacher report uh
now about a year ago or so he wrote
about rogers you know he called him a
world-class
grudge holder and he's right and
so you know i don't wanna underestimate
if you cross him and he just really
feels like he's been wrong
i don't want to underestimate the
chances that he might actually follow
through
but you're probably right it probably is
more 80 20 he has
he has all the leverage i mean the
packers have uh
have almost all the leverage on this um
but you know i kind of think of some
nightmare scenarios where
you know he's let's say he shows up i
think they have until a player has until
week
like it's nine or ten i think where if
they show up by then then the season
counts on their contract so it's an
accrued season
and so he'll be another season into his
contract
so if he shows up then they'll have half
a season in
and you know if love or whoever's
playing is playing okay then
you know i would assume you'd still put
rogers in but what if they're already
out of the playoff race
so there might be a point where if he
does sit maybe early in the season
they would trade him maybe even in camp
if they got an offer
that just blew their socks off um you
know maybe they would
they would do the deal then so i you
know i always keep that in mind but
you're probably right probably is more
eighty twenty that he that he's their
quarterback but i just have a little
voice in the back of my head about you
know
be cautious you never know you know how
far he might be willing to go on this so
that's why i go with 60 40 it's probably
it's probably just being overly cautious
on that
well uh it's going to be an interesting
uh you know 90 plus plus days i think
before that thursday night kickoff where
we're at camp is about to kick off in
what about five weeks or so for the
green bay packers we'll know
a little more then i want you to take
some rest because your uh
your computer fingers are gonna need it
to type out these stories every
single day it's going to be high drama
it is you know i was here obviously when
um all the five stuff
happened and rogers was in the jordan
love position at that time
and it was wild and when roger and when
five showed up
i'd i'd never missed a training camp
practice i missed the full first week
because i had to be in the office
working the phones figuring how far
and it does make you wonder if this is
going to be something like that
or if maybe i think it's july 27th is
when camp is supposed to
start reporting date you know maybe he
shows up then and
it's all kind of put on hold semi hold
until uh
until next february or march well we're
looking forward to it i really
appreciate
you taking the time pete daugherty from
the green bay press gazette joining us
talking all things pot uh packers thanks
pete
yeah thanks for having me ryan hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here